hunter biden's business partner says joe
was in on hunter's business activities
the whole time
the fbi announces iranian interference
in the election and rudy giuliani finds
himself targeted by borat i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do
keep yourself safe at expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment and tonight is debate next
there's an awful lot of news but first
let's talk about how you can save some
money quickly and easily i'm talking
about that cell phone bill so you look
at that cell phone bill you are spending
a lot of money
you should be spending about half of
what you're spending but the fact is
that you're not spending
the proper amount because you are buying
unlimited data well are you using
unlimited data
the answer of course is no the reason
that these cell phone companies charge
you up the wazoo is they assume you're
going to use extraordinary levels of
data you never use
you're basically buying out an entire
airplane when you're using a couple of
seats well instead of doing that
why don't you just get the same exact
coverage as you would get with verizon
at t
and t-mobile but instead of paying a
fortune instead pay a lot less
go to pure talk usa right now look at
your cell phone bill where it shows data
usage the average person who switches to
pure talk is using less than four gigs
of data a month the big carriers are
charging you unlimited data that's how
pure talk saves the average person over
400 bucks a year on their wireless
service unlimited talk text two gigs of
data all for just 20 bucks a month if
you go over on data usage they don't
charge you for it
switching to pure talk it's the easiest
decision you will make today so
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben
shapiro when you do you'll save 50 off
your first month dial pound 250 say
keyword ben
shapiro pure talk simply smarter
wireless style pound 250
say ben shapiro to get started and save
a bunch on your cell phone bill okay so
late last night news broke via the new
york post
that hunter biden's business partner his
old business partner
has confirmed that the email exchanges
that we have seen via the new york post
are not only real
but that joe biden was in on hunter
biden's business activities now remember
the original story here is that hunter
biden we knew this i mean this was
absolutely clear
hunter biden was jet setting around the
world picking up bags of cash and he
admitted openly
on national television just last year
that if his last name were not biden he
would not have been able to do that
joe claimed that he was ignorant of all
of these sorts of activity sure hunter
was
grabbing a ride with him on air force
two over to china while he was vice
president of the united states but you
know that was just all in good fun
the fact is that he was completely
separated off from what hunter was doing
and there was no indication that hunter
was corrupt anyway
and that was the story well then the new
york post broke email suggesting
that a meeting had actually been
brokered between a ukrainian oligarch
working for barisma
and joe biden by hunter biden and then
another email exchange or a couple more
email exchanges tended to suggest
that maybe just maybe joe biden was
receiving some of the proceeds of hunter
biden's nefarious business activity so
we went from
hunter is doing bad stuff and joe
doesn't know about it too hunter is
doing bad stuff and joe does know about
it too hunter is doing bad stuff and joe
is in on it
right that is the the evolution of the
story over the last couple of weeks well
last night the other shoe dropped and it
turns out that one of
hunter biden's business partners is now
confirming that joe biden was
in on a lot of hunter biden's business
activities and actually making money off
of them according to the new york post
michael goodwin reporting
we learned that biden has been secretly
playing ftse with china a statement on
wednesday night asserting that the
former vice president
was a willing and eager participant in a
family scheme to make millions
of to make millions of dollars by
partnering with a shady chinese
communist firm
is a singular event in a presidential
race already overflowing with drama and
intrigue
the design of my assertion believable
because it aligns with earlier
information we know to be true
came in a statement by tony belinsky who
describes himself as a former partner of
hunter biden
joe biden and joe's brother jim in the
china scheme
bob linskin loads his bill of
accusations in blunt but precise
language
and detail he actually released a rather
long statement
to the new york post here's what it says
my name is tony bobilinski
the facts set forth below are true and
accurate they are not any form of
domestic or foreign disinformation
any suggestions to the contrary is false
and offensive i am
i'm the recipient of the email published
seven days ago by the new york post
which showed a copy to hunter biden and
rob walker that email is genuine
this afternoon i received a request from
the senate committee on homeland
security and government affairs and the
senate committee on finance requesting
all documents relating to my business
affairs with the biden family
as well as various foreign entities and
individuals i have extensive relevant
records and communications and i intend
to produce those items to both
committees in the immediate future
i am the grandson of a 37-year army
intelligence officer the son of a
20-plus year career naval officer and
the brother of a 28-year career naval
flight officer
i myself served our country for four
years and left the navy as lieutenant
bob linski
i held a high-level security clearance
and was an instructor and then cto for
naval nuclear power training command
i take great pride in in the time my
family and i served this country i'm
also not a political person
what few campaign contributions i have
made in my life were to democrats
if the media and big tech companies had
done their jobs over the past several
weeks
i would be irrelevant in this story
given my long-standing service and
devotion to this great country i could
no longer allow my family's name to be
associated or tied to russian
disinformation or implied lies and false
narratives dominating the media right
now after leaving the military says
bobalenski i became an
institutional investor investing
extensively around the world and on
every continent
i've traveled to over 50 countries i
believe hands down we live in the
greatest country in the world
what i'm outlining is fact i know it's
fact because i lived it i am ceo of
cinehawk holdings which was a
partnership between the chinese
operating
through cefc chairman yi and the biden
family i was brought into the company to
be the ceo by james gilliar and hunter
biden
the reference to the big guy in the much
publicized may 13 2017 email
is in fact a reference to joe biden the
other jb referenced in that email is jim
biden
joe's brother okay so the email that he
is talking about is this may 13th 2017
email that suggested that 20 of the
company was to be held for hunter biden
and 10 was to go to quote-unquote the
big guy this is the email that
implicates joe biden in possible actual
corrupt activity
hunter biden called his dad the big guy
or my chairman according to tony
boblinski
and frequently referenced asking him for
his sign off or advice on various
potential deals that we were discussing
i've seen vice president biden saying he
never talked to hunter about his
business i've seen firsthand that's not
true because it wasn't just hunter's
business they said they were putting the
biden family name and its legacy on the
line
i realized the chinese were not really
focused on a healthy financial roi
return on investment
they were looking at this as a political
or influence investment once i realized
that hunter wanted to use the company as
his personal piggy bank by just taking
money out of it as soon as it came from
the chinese
i took steps to prevent that from
happening the johnson report this would
be the
ron johnson report from the senate
intelligence committee or homeland
security committee
connected some dots in a way that
shocked me it made me realize the bidens
had gone behind my back and gotten paid
millions of dollars by the chinese
even though they told me they hadn't and
wouldn't do that to their partners i
would ask the biden family to address
the american people and outline the
facts so i can go back to being
irrelevant
and so i'm not in put in a position to
have to answer these questions for them
i don't have a political axe to grind i
just saw behind the biden curtain and i
grew concerned with what i saw the biden
family aggressively leveraged the biden
family name to make millions of dollars
from foreign entities even though some
were from the communist
controlled the chinese god bless america
that is the statement
of tony babilinski okay so if that is
true
then that is a massive massive bombshell
obviously because now you are looking at
a person who should have been in a
position to know
saying that joe biden was in on all of
hunter biden's business activities
apparently while he was serving in the
government
right while joe biden was serving in the
government apparently he was working
with hunter biden
to clear checks is the accusation here
by tony bobolinski
now the accusation is credible if tony
bobolinsky was in the position that he's
talking about which apparently he was
if he was then i don't see why the media
can avoid asking questions about this
any longer after all we are told
that an allegation can be judged
credible on its face and then requires
questioning
remember when christine blasey ford came
forward with an accusation that brett
kavanaugh had raped her back during his
teenage years
some 30 to 40 years ago and this was
treated
as a credible accusation until the point
when it fell apart well
if somebody makes an accusation like
this on the record by name
and they say that they were in the know
and that hunter biden
was negotiating on behalf of joe biden
trade deals or or some sort of
investment deal
with a chinese front group and joe biden
was set to make money off of that
well then some serious questions ought
to be asked of hunter and joe biden
as i've said before this is not hard
right all the journalistic community has
to do is their job all they have to do
is say to joe biden
you know you said that you didn't know
about anything hunter biden was doing we
have pictures of you with kazakh
entrepreneurs we have a picture of you
you know with hunter biden getting off
that airplane at on air force two
we now have reports that you were
meeting with high-ranking members of the
chinese business community at hunter's
behest
and we now have this report so what's
the deal did you know or did you not
know
and it's not going to be sufficient for
you to simply say that
you don't have to answer any questions
because donald trump is the focus of the
campaign that is
that is an ending around of the issue
you actually have to answer
those sorts of questions will the media
do any of that
probably not the fact is that the media
are so in the bag for biden at this
point that they've been more focused on
blocking the dissemination of the story
and reporting on how the story was
reported that they have on the actual
content of the story they are deeply
deeply hesitant to ask joe biden
anything about this stuff because they
are afraid that the answer might mean
that donald trump wins a victory
and the media have decided donald trump
must not win this election
and therefore they're simply not going
to ask questions about it
at all right they will they will go
along for three years with the
allegations of the steele dossier
claiming that robert mueller was in the
background
putting together a damning case against
donald trump that would end with his
indictment for
collusion with russia none of that
materialized but when it comes to this
they will not ask
questions they won't and in fact they
get angry if you ask them to ask
questions so for example brian stelter
has a new book from cnn captain reliable
sources over here
he he was interviewed by a long-time
congressional reporter named susan
ferrecchio
and she challenged him over the veracity
of hunter biden's emails and brian
stelter got very angry about this
because members of the media don't like
to be called on the fact that they have
an extraordinary double standard when it
comes to reporting
stories that are obviously stories here
is brian stelter losing his mind when
asked very simple questions about why
the media double standard with regard to
for example
the steele dossier in russian collusion
and hunter biden's emails
bottom line is we don't know what is
real and what is fake in these emails if
there is anything real in them
yeah but that doesn't stop any from from
reporting the mueller and the dossier
and all that stuff
i understand that you have a lot of
resentment about it now now we have
ethics
okay now we have ethics now don't you
dare don't you dare act like newsrooms
didn't have ethics
in 2017 and 2018. well i know they think
well
you can't you can don't dare me all you
want brian i've been doing this for 30
years so
say whatever you want it's my view
meanwhile joe biden knowing just how
extraordinarily in the bag the media are
for him
he keeps saying that the story's already
been debunked the story's not been
debunked not one aspect of the story has
been debunked
members of the biden campaign have said
that these emails are authentic
or at least they have refused to deny
that they are authentic i mean when
asked repeatedly
not one detail of the story has yet been
biden has not addressed any aspect of
the story
so he was asked by a media member from
wisconsin via zoom
about this and he just said i'm not
going to answer any questions on this
because you know i just don't think it's
legit
is there any legitimacy to senator
johnson's claims
none whatsoever this is the same garbage
rudy giuliani
trump's henchmen it's the last it's
effort in this desperate campaign to
smear me and my family
even the man who served with him on that
committee the former
nominee for the republican party said
there's no basis to this
and you know and all and the vast
majority of the intelligence people have
come out and said
there's no basis at all okay that's not
everyone should be ashamed of themselves
not a word of this is correct not a word
of this is correct
okay the allegations that are being made
are on the basis of new information that
has been uncovered and presented
over the course of the last three weeks
no one in the intelligence community
with any credibility
and with any inside information has
found that this is in fact quote unquote
russian disinformation
nonetheless that is what biden is
relying upon he's relying on the
the folks over twitter and facebook to
suppress the dissemination of the story
so that he can be elected president it's
that simple and joe biden is out there
dr joe
she's out there suggesting that these
are just smears against the family
this election is not about joe biden or
jill biden or
kamala or doug it is about the american
people
the american people don't want to hear
these smears against my family
the american people are struggling right
now i mean they're in the midst of all
this chaos they're trying to figure out
how to put food on the table you know
they don't have jobs they
they need health care americans don't
want to hear this
distract and spin americans don't want
to hear it therefore you shouldn't even
bother asking the questions as dr jill
meanwhile kamal o'hara says
joe wouldn't talk about other people's
kids he wouldn't talk about other
people's kids joe he's just such a nice
guy
well i mean i think that he might if he
thought that the election depended on it
in fact i have a feeling that within the
next week and a half if the hunter biden
email story continues to percolate
that you will see kamala harris and joe
biden mentioning the supposed
allegations of corruption against the
trump kids i would suspect that that is
the case and you'll start hearing that
from the dnc very shortly
here's kamala harris saying this that
people want to hear about how we're
going to
help working people get through the end
of the month and pay their rent
that's what people care about and you
know one of the things i love about joe
biden
he doesn't take on or talk about other
people's kids
okay sure sure we'll see how long that
lasts because all these standards go by
the wayside as soon as they become
politically inconvenient here's the
bottom line
the biden campaign has called the lid on
the campaign the campaign's over from
their perspective all they're going to
do is run out the clock
and maybe it's a good strategy if you
look at the polls right now joe biden is
certainly in the lead
right if you just look at the polling
data he's in the lead but that could
change
the only thing that would change is some
sort of extraneous shock to the system
that shot could come in the form of the
hunter by an email so best policy
lock down and just wait on it now right
now the polls seem to be tightening just
a little bit
we have seen two polls in the last three
days that suggest that this race is a
lot closer than previously suggested
we've got this ibd tippp poll that came
out yesterday that suggests that biden
is up only to 49 to 47 over trump
let's put it this way if the popular
vote comes down to a two-point margin
trump probably wins the election
there's another poll from rasmussen that
suggests that biden is up only three
points 49 to 46
and that's not enough of a margin for
him to win the election if it's that
close in all likelihood
trump wins those swing states again
there are two other polls one from
reuters one from the economist both with
biden up nine so we have a real division
between the polls and how they are
seeing this thing when it comes to the
battleground states everything
seems to be closing within a certain
margin of error
if we look at the states right now biden
is up only by about two points in
florida
he's up about five points in
pennsylvania that's according to the
real club politics polling average
he's up much larger in michigan he's
only up about five in wisconsin he's
about two in north carolina he's about
three in arizona so if there's
any movements in the polls toward trump
like any solid movement in the polls
toward trump
then biden is in real trouble he may be
up nationally and he may be looking like
he's in good shape they're still two
weeks to this election
so biden's goal here was to call a lid
on the campaign and you can see it in
real time
right biden's doing zoom calls and his
people are jumping in and being like you
know what that's all the time we have
we'll catch you later joe biden's
campaign is just a
leave me alone focus on donald trump
campaign we'll see if that's effective
if the hunter biden story begins to
actually break
here is a joe biden staffer on a zoom
call literally just calling a lid in the
middle of the actual interview
we owe them a great deal i mean are you
worried about
that's all the time we have for today
can i ask one more please
okay well that's all the time we'll
catch you later catch you later and
that's the theme of the biden campaign
that's all the time we have for today
then we can get back to yelling at
donald trump okay in just a second
we got to talk about some other breaking
news this from the fbi suggesting that
the iranians are attempting to interfere
in the election on behalf of
wait for it wait for joe biden i know
we're not supposed to talk about that
only russian interference on behalf of
trump
is what we're supposed to talk about
we're never supposed to talk about
chinese interference or iranian
interference both of which have been
confirmed
by the fbi on behalf of joe biden but
that broke out into the open yesterday
with a late night press conference we'll
talk about that in just one second first
let's talk about the thousand reasons to
protect your home so maybe you're
concerned about crime
or maybe you are just wanting to keep
track of your kids i know that i've got
three kids under the age of seven and
that means that they are little suicide
machines running around attempting to
hurt themselves all the time
well one thing that gives me peace of
mind is knowing who's at the front door
knowing what's going on all over my
property and that's why i rely on ring
ring has security products for every
corner of your home inside and out best
of all you can see it all in one simple
app with ring you can keep an eye on
your home no matter where you are right
from your phone
if somebody stops by or something is
going on ring will let you know it's
peace of mind anytime knowing that your
home is protected
whatever you call home ring has
everything you need to protect it you
can see and speak to whoever is at your
door from anywhere with video doorbells
keep an eye on every corner of your
house with the easy to install indoor
and outdoor cams protect your whole home
with ring alarm a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install
yourself i've been using ring for years
to protect my property there are
situations in which it has come in
extremely handy namely like
when my kids are able to hurt themselves
and i just sprint from one room to the
other to stop them
with get a special offer on the ring
welcome kit right now at ring.com
ben it comes with rings rings video
doorbell 3 and chime pro it's the
perfect way to start your ring
experience plus
free two-day shipping go to ring.com
that is ring.com
ben okay meanwhile the us government
concluded last night that iran
has been attempting to manipulate the
elections john ratcliffe the director of
national intelligence
he announced yesterday that this was
happening so did apparently christopher
wray of
the fbi the fbi warned that there was an
attempt
to manipulate the elections here was the
director of national intelligence john
ratcliffe
explaining that iran is attempting to
interfere on behalf of joe biden
we have already seen iran sending
spoofed emails designed to intimidate
voters
incite social unrest and damage
president trump
additionally iran is distributing other
content
to include a video that implies that
individuals
could cast fraudulent ballots even from
overseas
this video and any claims about such
allegedly fraud fraudulent ballots
are not true okay so
there's an attempt to undermine
credibility of the election and it is
coming in fact
from yes russia but also iran also iran
one particular aspect of this story is
that iran is behind an email operation
that was directed at intimidating voters
that they were masquerading as the proud
boys and sending emails to various
democrats and threatening them according
to the washington post
the disclosure by the director of
national intelligence john ratcliffe at
hastily called the news conference mark
the first time this election cycle a
foreign adversary
has been accused of targeting specific
voters in a bid to undermine democratic
confidence
just four years after russian online
operations marred the 2016
presidential vote now of course russian
operations in 2016 there's not a lot of
proof that it shifted anybody
all of their supposed misdirection on
places like facebook it amounted to a
tiny
drop in the enormous ocean of social
media content
however this is a little more serious
the claim that iran was behind an email
operation which came into view on
tuesday as democrats in several states
reported receiving emails demanding they
vote for president trump
was leveled without specific evidence
other u.s officials speaking privately
stressed that russia still remained
the major threat to the 2020 election up
well you can always find somebody in the
intelligence community to talk about
russia
russia russia because trump of course is
so bad however
it was the director of national
intelligence john ratcliffe suggesting
in fact that what was happening here
is that the iranians masquerading as the
proud boys
had been attempting to email people and
and gin up
election interference on behalf of joe
biden right so it wasn't meant to
intimidate the democrats so much as it
was meant
to promote the idea that the proud boys
were acting on behalf of donald trump
and therefore attempting to suppress
the vote on thursday iran summoned the
swiss envoy in tehran
which handles u.s affairs there to
condemn the quote-unquote baseless
accusations of meddling
in the u.s election according to alireza
merusefi these accusations are nothing
more than another scenario to undermine
voter confidence and are absurd iran has
no interest in interfering in the us
election
and no preference for the outcome okay
that is obviously untrue iran would
certainly prefer joe biden
donald trump has killed the iran deal
donald trump has facilitated the rise of
an israeli arab alliance in the region
donald trump has cut off the iranian
regime at the knees and joe biden
pledges to prop them up again so
obviously the iranians prefer
the biden campaign and they've made this
perfectly obvious i mean this is this is
not a secret in any way shape or form
the emails claim to be from a pro-trump
group called the proud boys but evidence
had mounted
they were in fact the work of another
hidden actor u.s officials said that was
iran a nation that has increasingly
clashed with the president in recent
years oh
see iran was totally fine until trump
was elected
then iran clashed with the president
according to the washington post not
that they murdered a bunch of american
soldiers in iraq
not that iran has been a threat to
american national security since 1979.
no it's really just trump officials did
stress the integrity
of the election was intact former fbi
well fbi director christopher wray was
standing next to radcliff he said we're
not going to tolerate foreign
interference or any criminal activity
that threatens the sanctity of your vote
or undermines public confidence
in the outcome of the election ratcliffe
accused iran of using the data to send
spoofed emails designed to intimidate
voters incite social unrest
and damage president trump naturally
senate minority leader chuck schumer
immediately told nbc's rachel maddow
from the briefing i had the strong
impression
it was much rather to undermine
confidence in election and not aimed at
any particular figure oh it wasn't about
helping
it wasn't about helping biden as it
turns out it was just about undermining
election confidence
generally oh oh so that's what's
happening here what exactly were these
emails
well the emails were apparently
engineered by someone working at the
best of the iranian government according
to a u.s official who spoke on the
condition of anonymity because of the
matter's sensitivity
the operation appeared to exploit a
vulnerability in the proud boys online
network
the message is advised that the group
was quote in possession of all your
information
and instructed voters to change their
party registration and cast their
ballots for trump
you will vote for trump on election day
or we will come after you warned the
emails which by tuesday night were said
to have reached voters in as many as
four states three of them contested
swing states
u.s officials said the operation was not
terribly sophisticated and was disclosed
before it could have any
major impact ratcliffe also confirms
that iran is distributing a video
implying that individuals
should cast fraudulent ballots even from
overseas
the video was posted on a twitter
account that has since been suspended
okay so there is so the good news is
that the fbi uncovered this
we also know that iran wants biden to be
president we know that china wants biden
to be president which should tell you
something about where we stand on
foreign policy won't get any foreign
policy tonight in the debate by the way
there'll be no foreign policy we'll have
two debates no foreign policy foreign
policy by the way
is the greatest point of differentiation
between trump and biden bain has been
wrong on every foreign policy issue of
his lifetime
every single one without exception it's
incredible
okay but it is important to note here
that the iranian disinformation the same
people who are shouting russian
disinformation were promoting iranian
disinformation
and they were promoting the idea that
the proud boys had actually sent these
emails the
the lincoln project bros who are
clearing that sweet sweet grifter
grifter cache they put out a tweet
promoting iranian disinformation
actually just a few days ago quote the
proud boys are attempting to scare
voters away from the polls this is
punishable by up to a year in jail and a
blatant attempt to prevent people from
voting let's find them
and make them famous i i haven't seen
the uh the lincoln project suspended
from twitter as of yet and new york post
is still suspended from twitter by the
way for printing the hunter biden story
but uh apparently totally fine for the
lincoln project to promote actual
iranian disinformation so that's
exciting stuff
okay meanwhile we draw closer to the
debate a lot of debates inside the trump
camp over how to handle
this debate should trump present a
positive mission for the
vision for the country or should he
attack biden
well i mean here's the reality the
positive vision for the country that
that ship has sailed i don't think that
donald trump talking in in glowing
positive ways
is going to be particularly effective
everybody has their perception of trump
the only thing that could change in this
race is the perception of biden
and that is why the hunter biden email
story is so important with regard to
donald trump's campaign we'll get to
that
in just one second first let us talk
about how easy it is for
hackers to grab your information and use
it against you there's one particular
method of hacking one particular method
of identity theft that is extremely
damaging
it is called home title theft okay
here's how easy it is
the legal title to your home it's
digitized is kept on government and
business servers and in the cloud where
they can be hacked
a cyber he finds your home's title
forges your signature on a quick claim
deed
stating you sold your home to him done
then he just takes out loans against
your home until all your equity is gone
leaves you in debt
you won't know until the collection
calls pour in insurance doesn't protect
you
neither do common identities have
programs this is why you should check
out home
title lock today home title lock puts a
barrier around your home's title the
instant they detect tampering they help
shut it down cold go to home title
lock.com
register your address to see if you're
already a victim then use code radio for
30 free days of protection that is code
radio
at home title lock dot com once more
home title lock dot com
use code radio and get 30 free days of
protection
make sure that nobody is taking your
most valuable asset and then subjecting
it to the predations
of the identity theft black web use code
radio home
title lock.com go check them out right
now okay so
how's this debate going to play out
tonight according to the new york times
republicans would like to see the
president
to offer an affirmative vision for the
country and draw policy contrasts with
mr biden in terms of the resonate with
the few undecided voters remaining
but trump with his history of
indiscipline and invective has struggled
to define biden this year and he is
running short
on time trump's advisers hope he can get
under biden's skin on thursday at the
debate in nashville that will begin
at 9 00 pm eastern they've also urged
the president not to interrupt
biden repeatedly well that can't really
happen too much because they've now the
ability to cut the mics
the president in order to have a
successful debate has to go on offense
without being offensive said brett
o'donnell
a republican strategist who has coast
coached candidates in debates the
american people care more about their
own family than they do about the family
of hunter biden especially during the
pandemic okay
that's true that's true but it is also
true that if people start to perceive
joe biden as a corrupt old washington
crony which in all likelihood he is i
mean going back years and years and
years there are all sorts of reports
of a son hunter making bank off of
connections to the biden name this goes
all the way back to
joe biden shilling on behalf of credit
card companies while his son was picking
up checks from some of the people
lobbying on behalf of those bills that
that fact could harm joe biden and it's
important that trump bring it up
for sure well it's because the hunter
biden story
is uh is important to the trump campaign
that you're starting to see
uh what looks very much like sort of an
organized campaign
to go after rudy giuliani now rudy
giuliani this is a this is a dude
who is likely to uh to get himself into
trouble on a fairly regular basis
rudy giuliani is a wild character for
sure
that is that is for certain that does
not mean that the media are not willing
to run with
overtly false stories about rudy
giuliani so yesterday there were two
stories about rudy giuliani it turns out
that both were basically false so the
first came courtesy of
borat so borat apparently was phil
sasha baron cohen whose uh films are are
wildly overrated
and when i say they're widely overrated
i mean when he's actually acting he's
quite good
when he's not acting when he's doing
this sort of borat schtick
it's honestly it's kind of boring and
ridiculous okay
when when he's acting like he did this
netflix series
on an israeli spy named uh ellie cohen
and it's
really good it's really quite good i've
heard that his performance in the uh
aaron sorkin film on the
chicago seven that that's pretty good
too but the borat stuff has gotten real
old one of the reasons it's gotten old
is because he tends to target ordinary
americans i don't really care if he
targets
public figures and politicians for sort
of these pranks and pratfalls
but he goes after ordinary americans and
tries to humiliate them and very often
uses their politeness against them so he
will go say something deeply offensive
nobody will speak out against him or
punch him in the face and then i'll be
like ah these people must agree with
that
it's a really cheap tactic okay so when
it comes to rudy giuliani
he apparently he and a woman named maria
bakalova
who plays his daughter in his new borat
re redo it's borah at the return
they meet with rudy giuliani according
to
nbc news rudy giuliani president donald
trump's personal lawyer fell for an
embarrassing sasha baron cohen prank and
the soon-to-be-released movie sequel to
borat in the film
a copy of which was obtained by nbc news
giuliani and a young woman posing as a
reporter who was part of consting can be
seen going into a hotel bedroom for
drinks at the woman's invitation
after completing what giuliani
apparently believed to be a real
interview about the coveted pandemic and
trump's response to it
the incident occurred as giuliani 76 was
trying to remove his microphone with the
help of the actress which has been used
as part of the movie's interview
with him the film which is being
released friday on amazon prime video
shows giuliani reclining on a bed and
putting his hand down his pants and
moving it around for what appears to be
a few seconds while the actor is playing
borat's teenage daughter maria bakalova
who's pretending to be a television
reporter stands in front of him at this
point borat runs into the room shouting
she's 15
she's too old for you giuliani quickly
sits up and appears to be startled by
the presence of cohen who has a pink
outfit that resembles
lingerie giuliani asks him why are you
dressed like this cohen has brought
response she's my daughter please take
me instead i don't want you giuliani
replies he then apparently called the
cops
on boar app giuliani claimed i love this
i love this nbc news listen to how nbc
news characterizes this
in a tweet wednesday afternoon giuliani
claimed without evidence that the quote
borat video is a complete fabrication
i was tucking in my shirt after taking
off the recording equipment giuliani
tweeted and no time before during or
after the interview was i ever
inappropriate
if sasha baron cohen implies otherwise
he is a stone-cold liar
beyond what is seen in the movie nbc
news does not know what happened before
or after the film's incident
the film also features the scene in
which bakalova asked giuliani about the
coronal virus pandemic he responds china
manufactured covenanting and
deliberately spread it
all over the world i don't think anybody
was eating bats he adds before jokingly
asking her if she's ever eaten a bat
he appears to agree to eat one if she
will the prank is one of the most
notable in the borat sequel
okay now giuliani had said in early july
this happened that he called the new
york city police department after the
setup he thought it was some sort of
blackmail routine
giuliani said this guy comes running and
wearing a crazy what i would say was a
pink transgender outfit
this person comes in yelling and
screaming i thought this must be a scam
or a shakedown so i reported it to the
cops he then ran away
i only later realized it must have been
sasha baron cohen i thought about all
the people he previously fooled i felt
good about myself because he didn't get
me okay so this was reported yesterday
in great defining detail by the media
now quick rule of thumb for all public
figures never go into a private area
with a
with a the pence rule applies okay don't
go into a private area
with a female reporter particularly like
a hotel bedroom and nothing good is
going to happen there
okay that is just on a moral level on a
a level of caution
don't be an idiot right this one falls
under don't be an idiot for rudy
giuliani however
however what the film apparently shows
is not rudy giuliani reaching down his
pants jeffrey's tube in style
it does appear to show giuliani who is
76 attempting to get a microphone
off of himself ben dreyfus who is
certainly no right winger
he's the editorial director of mother
jones he tweeted this out quote
i have now seen the scene with rudy
giuliani and notice creepy for other
reasons it is being described on twitter
in a false way
he does not have his hand down his shirt
his pants in a sexual way he is tucking
his shirt back in
after she untucks it removing his mic
also the bad thing is a joke she prompts
and he just politely agrees
right so it is not that giuliani is
suggesting they eat bat together the
scene is confusingly edited for comedic
purposes which makes sense since this is
a comedy film and not a 60 minutes
expose
it would be good to keep that in mind in
light of the flattening of media where
everything can seem like everything else
there are parts of this scene that are
creepy though in the same scene he
passed around her lower back in a very
weird way
you will be able to find stuff you don't
like watching it but i do not think the
description of the hands and the pants
thing
is fair okay so this is
this is being obviously misconstrued
deliberately by the media right nbc news
says
that there's no reason to to suggest
he's saying without evidence that the
things of fabrication well no
the take on it is a fabrication right
that giuliani was uh reaching down into
his pants for
things other than tucking in his shirt
giuliani tweeted out the borat videos a
complete fabrication i was tucking in my
shirt after taking off the recording
equipment
at no time before during or after the
interview was i ever inappropriate if
sasha baron cohen implies otherwise he's
a stone cold liar
in fact the new york post today reports
it looks to me like an exaggeration
through editing
as soon as i realized it was a setup i
called the police which has been noted
in the
hollywood reporter article on july 8th
this is an effort to blunt my relentless
exposure of the criminality and
depravity of joe biden and his entire
family
deadline hollywood reports that caa had
a distribution screening in september
where there was no mention of the scene
holding any importance
we are preparing for much bigger dumps
off of the hard drive from hell of which
joe biden will be unable to defend
or hide from i have the receipts because
giuliani is claiming that this is all
basically a setup now two things can be
true at once again
giuliani should not be going into hotel
rooms with 24 year old women
this is a foolish move it can also be
true that he didn't do anything actually
inappropriate and according to kyle
smith of national review who has also
seen the scene he didn't actually do
anything inappropriate
so that's that doesn't matter the media
i mean this was the headline on drudge
rudy two exclamation points picture of
rudy lying down on the bed putting his
hands down his pants
right deliberately misleading stuff
falsely
reported stuff i don't see twitter
censoring any of that stuff
twitter also apparently did not censor
this story in which
a college student posed as ivanka trump
and pretended
that he had had text exchanges with rudy
giuliani
it turns out that that was not true it
was retweeted it was put out there by
half of the blue checkmark media
yesterday this idea that giuliani had
been texting with ivanka because he's an
idiot
according to media supposed text
messages posted by college student nick
roberts onto twitter allegedly since
president donald trump lawyer rudy
giuliani are not real
it is satire roberts told mediaite on
wednesday afternoon it's a conversation
i had with my brother he added
most people have caught on to it being a
joke but then the national people picked
it up the college students stated
before saying that after mediaite's
tweet reporters began reaching out in
large numbers
there is there are these fake text
messages that suggested that ivanka
trump was uh was
texting giuliani and giuliani was
returning
the text rachel maddow tweeted out i
can't even
david friedlander tweeted out rudy seems
to have learned his lesson his
tightening protocols checking ids and is
now being taken in by someone claiming
to be ivanka trump but who is in fact
the vice president of the college
democrats
of indiana david freelander by the way
is the editor
he's a contributing editor at politico
magazine journalisming up the wazoo just
tremendous levels of journalism
msnbc's stephanie rule also fell for the
tweet i can't
i can't again you can doubt rudy
giuliani's word you're perfectly free to
do that
without falsifying information or
reporting false information have any of
these people been suspended from twitter
for uh for pushing false information
have any of them been suppressed on
facebook for pushing false information
no but the new york post story on hunter
biden
you still cannot tweet out that link as
far as i know and the new york post
is still suspended from twitter don't
worry the media are not biased in any
way
not in any way okay meanwhile
the the question of the election is
starting to turn
to what comes next if joe biden is
elected amazing we had to get to two
weeks before the election for people to
start asking
basic questions about what is going to
happen if joe biden is in fact elected
as i mentioned yesterday on the show and
talked about at length there is this
bizarre view that if joe biden is
elected all bad things stop
everything goes back to supposed normal
all of the clouds are lifted
covid goes away the economy rebounds
everybody is nice to each other the lion
lies down with the lamb and all of this
but here's the problem joe biden is a
person with an actual agenda
he's going to be handling a caucus that
is basically led by representative
alexander ocasio-cortez chuck schumer
the senate minority leader should he
become senate majority leader
will wildly veer to the left he's
already been tutting diane feinstein a
long time
tentpole for the democratic party he's
doing so because he's afraid that aoc is
going to primary him
inside of new york state so watch for
the democrats to move wildly
to the left joe biden you know he may
try to
i would say i don't know pat these
people on the head
and then tell them to go along their
merry way that is unlikely to be
successful
we'll discuss that in just one second
first let us talk about
the fact that you're consuming an awful
lot of media these days i mean we are
two weeks out from an election and
a lot of us are still stuck at home and
we can't go to a movie theater and this
means what you need is a great pair of
wireless earbuds that's why i recommend
wireless earbuds from raycon
raycon's newest model the everyday e25s
those are the best ones yet six hours of
playtime seamless bluetooth pairing more
bass
more compact design a noise isolating
fit raycon earbuds they're stylish and
discreet
no dangling wires no stems give them a
try raycon has a 45 day free return
policy so you can make sure they are the
pair of wireless earbuds
for you for a limited time get 15 off
your order at byraycon.com
that is b-u-i-r-a-y-c-o-n.com for a
special 15
discount on raycon wireless earbuds make
sure to check it out now while the deal
is running
by raycon calm slash ben one of the
things i love about my raycons they fit
my ear perfectly so a lot of other one
size
fits all routines they don't fit my ear
exactly right raycon
they send you this this metal card it
has a bunch of different fits for your
ear so you can customize those raycons
they fit your ear absolutely well also
you can get them in a bunch of different
styles and and colors so you can really
personalize these things and they are
excellent and they're going to cost you
half of what the competitors would cost
you and you get 15
off today slash at that's by raycon
dot com slash ben okay in just a second
we'll get to what is on the agenda
for joe biden and barack obama hits the
campaign trail again remember when we
were told
that ex-president there was a norm
ex-presidents like george w bush they go
away barack obama has no intention of
doing so we'll get to that in just one
second first
this year has been insane statues being
toppled
radical rioting looting in american
cities an entire democratic party
embracing the 1619 project
it feels like america is coming apart
well that's because it kind of
is there are underlying ideological
problems in the country there is
an american philosophy is the philosophy
of the declaration of independence
it is the philosophy that undergirds the
constitution of the united states
there's an american culture of
entrepreneurialism a culture of
tolerance for other people's rights
there's an american history that is the
story of an excellently founded country
attempting to live up to its ideals all
of this is being denied by what i call
disintegrationist
is what i write about in my book how to
destroy america in three easy steps you
should go pick up a copy today it is not
merely
a take on on what the radical left is
doing to the country and how they have
ideologically shifted the country
the book is really a refresher for
conservatives it's great for young
people
it's important for them to know why
america is great why it was always great
and why
it will be great again go check out how
to destroy america in three easy steps
once more it is a pre-election must read
and a post-election must read
as well also ever since hillary clinton
lost in 2016
many in the press have suggested free
dissemination of information on social
media is the problem they say the big
problem is that facebook allowed
conservatives to
say what they want these sources from
the mainstream media to members of the
social media companies themselves
have pressured social media leaders to
reimpose from the top down a monopoly on
informational dissemination that existed
before the internet they're attempting
to re-establish a monopoly on
information from the mainstream media
this is the kind of garbage pushed
weekly by kara swisher and kevin roos at
the new york times and people like judd
they routinely tweet out lists of highly
trafficked pages on facebook in order to
not so suddenly imply that facebook is
gaming the system on behalf of
conservatives and trump
that's a lie it's an obvious lie that's
why this week our own co-ceo jeremy
boering launched a new podcast titled
enough
in his first episode released yesterday
jeremy takes on the leftist outlets
trying to get conservatives kicked off
facebook listen now at the link in the
description subscribe to jeremy's
podcast
to get his other rants about big
government big tech hollywood hypocrisy
and well anything else that comes to
mind when it comes to mine so
check it out if you like it leave review
make it a five star review so it gets
recommended to more people
also more information as with everything
in 2020 there's been a lot of drama with
the presidential debates but
we are ready for the next and final
debate it is happening tonight
tonight join us at 8 45 pm eastern
5 45 pm pacific for an all new episode
of daily wire backstage to watch the
debate with us and get our immediate
live reaction to this major political
event
even better join daily wire now as an
insider or all access member get 20
off with code debate you can watch all
the debate coverage live on our apple tv
or roku app members get our articles ad
free access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show exclusive
readers past content available only to
daily wire members if you're considering
an all-access membership you get to join
us on all access live every night for
online and live stream discussions
you also get not one but two leftist
years tumblers with your membership
as well as early sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wire products so
watch the debate with us on
dailywire.com youtube and facebook get
off your daily wire membership with code
debate when you sign up today you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so what exactly is the plan for for
democrats beyond the election well joe
biden
announced finally his plan with regard
to court packing
so his plan for court packing announced
it on cbs
this morning two weeks out from the
election it's a commission he says he is
going to
have a commission and that commission is
going to examine
the problems with the politicization of
the court he said it's a controversial
proposal that would add
nine justices to the supreme court he he
is going to
put out a a commission of course and
so here's the reality a lot of people on
the right are going to spin that as joe
biden
you know going soft on court packing
that he wants to core pack what it
actually suggests that he wants to kill
this thing softly he doesn't actually
want a court pack what he wants to do
is put out a sop to the various
democratic party constituencies
and then kind of let it die in the same
way the democrats keep calling for
commissions to explore slavery
reparations
without actually introducing a bill at
any point so they're going to do the
same thing with regard to court packing
which is somewhat quieting i mean i'm
glad they're not attempting to pack
the supreme court the question is
whether you think joe biden is actually
in control of his own administration
i think the answer to that is no let's
say that the democrats pass something in
the house let's say nancy pelosi is
pressured into pushing
a court-packing bill and let's say that
chuck schumer afraid of the aoc wing of
the democratic party
pushes that same bill you think that joe
biden's going to veto it
shall buy nate v doing anything coming
from the radicals in his party he is too
afraid of what they are going to do
he is too afraid that they will
undermine his ability to govern
do you think joe biden is more likely to
reach across the aisle to mitch
mcconnell or is he more likely to reach
back to his radical left especially
if the possibility arises that democrats
have a heavy majority in the house as
well as a majority in the senate at that
point he ain't reaching across the aisle
to republicans he is reaching over to
his radical left here is joe biden
however
basically attempting to kill the court
packing talk by
by kind of sopping his base if elected
what i will do is i'll put together a
national commission of
bipartisan commission of scholars
constitutional scholars
democrats republicans liberal
conservative
and i will ask them do over a
180 days come back to me with
recommendations as to how
to reform the court system because it's
getting out of whack
so you're telling us you're going to
study this issue about whether to pack
the court no whether there's a number of
alternatives that are go
well beyond packing meanwhile lurking in
the wings of course kamala harris joe
biden keeps saying that kamala harris is
ready to be president on day one yeah
that's what we're afraid of joe here was
joe biden talking about how his radical
vp would make an excellent president
i'm just convinced that we have to form
an administration
that looks and represents the american
people across the board
and also uh someone who is ready
god forbid on day one that they could
step up and be the president united
states and
i think kamala met all those
requirements okay
so you know that that'll be fun because
everybody knows in reality when you
elect joe biden you're not getting joe
biden you're getting
kamala harris it's worthwhile loading
that even joe biden is not exactly a
non-radical the man was a far-left
member of the united states senate
four years and if you are ready by the
way for more lockdowns get ready jill
biden yesterday was on the view
and dr jill an educator right she's not
a doctor doctor as in
if you have a heart attack jill ain't
saving you uh she is a she's she has her
doctorate in education i believe
but dr jill she says it is not safe to
go back to schools based on
the science by which she means no signs
at all here she was on the view so get
ready for more lockdowns if biden's
president
nobody wants to get back to school more
than the teachers
to the educators we'd give anything to
be back in our classrooms but we are
listening
to what the doctors and the scientists
are telling us and when it's safe to go
back
we'll go back but right now you know we
have to
do this remote learning okay so
they're gonna go for more lockdowns
you're gonna see joe biden basically
pushed around by his own base
that is not a shock in any way of course
meanwhile barack obama has reemerged on
the campaign trail
because obama wants his revenge obama
understands that donald trump's election
in 2020
in 2016 was a ringing rebuke of him
it was about hillary but it was also
about barack obama and there's always
been this sort of bizarro world
reverse polarization between trump and
obama
i've told you before one of my favorite
photos in all of human history is the
photo
of donald trump visiting the white house
after being elected and sitting next to
barack obama who has to hand the keys to
this place to donald trump and it's just
obama looking like he wants to die
while trump gives the trump finger the
drum finger oh yeah
yeah to the cameras and behind him and
behind them
is a bust of abraham lincoln looking at
the floor it is the funniest thing
in the entire world the fact is that all
donald trump is is the less
sophisticated and more brazen version of
barack obama from the right
right the everything that obama says
about donald trump is true of barack
obama it's one of the great ironies
of american political politics that
barack obama is seen as this
wonderful spokesperson for higher
american ideals when he very obviously
is not so every time you hear obama
speak you should recognize that he's
actually critiquing barack obama he just
doesn't even know it so obama was out on
the campaign trail
for joe biden yesterday in pennsylvania
and he said that you have to stop
tweeting at the television that doesn't
fix things
i get that this president wants full
credit for the economy he inherited
and zero blame for the pandemic that he
ignored
but you know what the job doesn't work
that way
tweeting at the television doesn't fix
things
making stuff up doesn't make people's
lives better
you've got to have a plan you've got to
put in the work
okay um that is a man who never had a
plan and really did not put in
tons of work and when i say he didn't
put in tons of work i'm not saying that
he was lazy i'm saying that he did not
care
about reaching across the aisle and
actually making sure that his proposals
got passed
his idea of work was signing executive
agreements executive orders
pen and phone governance and speaking to
media who just rubbed his ass every
single day i mean that was literally
his idea of the job also there's a great
irony to him suggesting that it's very
bad that trump tweets about the news
i remember the obama administration okay
i'm not 16 years old i'm 36 so i
remember the entirety of the obama
administration
barack obama found out about half the
things that happened inside his
administration
on the news obama said that hillary
clinton using a non-official system to
conduct government business
he said i found out about that through
news reports he said that he found out
about the va wait time scandal
on the news he said he found out about
the irs targeting conservative groups
on the news he said that he found out
about the doj issuing subpoenas for the
associated press phone records
on the news he said he found out about
fast and furious on the news
he said he found out about the air force
one flyover over new york city for a
photo op
he said he found out about that on the
news right barack obama was an observer
to his own administration according to
barack obama and now he's angry that
trump acts exactly the same way
barack obama broke all the precedents
donald trump was just the guy who
stomped all over them and ground them
into glass
and glass shards i mean he just into
sand
okay same thing so barack obama went
after trump's language he said he
emboldens others to be cruel and
divisive
well again i'm old enough to remember
the obama administration when it became
stuck in trade to suggest that your
political opponents were bitter clingers
who were evil nasty racist that people
as milk toast as mitt romney were evil
if you want to talk about people
emboldening the cruel and the divisive
barack obama was no wilting lily in that
particular department here's obama going
after trump
why would we expect and ex
accept this from the president of the
united states
and how why are folks making excuses for
that oh well that's just
that's just him no it's
no there are consequences
to these actions they embolden other
people
to be cruel and divisive
and racist oh okay so um when you were
suggesting
that police officers around the country
were systemically racist that didn't
embolden anyone
nobody when you went to a dallas police
memorial after a bunch of officers were
shot and talked about american police
being bad
that didn't embolden anyone it turns out
every
criticism that barack obama makes about
trump is also true of barack obama
he said that trump can't take the job
seriously now listen
i think a lot of this is true about
trump by the way i think trump doesn't
take the job particularly seriously i
think trump does act like he is
outside his own administration a lot i
think the trump's rhetoric is very often
bad
i also think that the world didn't begin
spinning when donald trump became
president and the reason you ended up
with trump is because of barack obama in
maine
here is here is barack obama saying that
trump can't take the job seriously this
one president i'll do an interview with
glozell
i have to appear on between two ferns
i'm gonna do a selfie stick
picture of myself in the oval office
this is the same barack obama who spent
a huge chunk of his presidency
hobnobbing with various celebrities
captain seriousness over here i never
thought
donald trump would embrace my vision
or continue my policies but i did hope
for the sake of the country that he
might show
some interest in taking the job
seriously
but it hasn't happened that dude
gasoline he hasn't shown any interest in
doing the work
i'm sorry he's just helping anybody but
himself and his friends i mean
barack obama's treating the president
he's so irritating he's so irritating
because the media gaslit
the country for eight long years he
gasled the country for eight long years
and he's still gaslighting the country
he was the apex of seriousness as a
human being he was just the most serious
he was the most considerate the most
thoughtful the man who was the most
in-depth in terms of his knowledge
the most bipartisan the most scandal
free
okay if you believe any of that you're
an idiot none of it was true
but we were told all of it was true and
therefore you're supposed to just listen
and believe my favorite part of obama's
little campaign stump speech
on behalf of joe biden yesterday a
couple things that they were my
favorites
so he uh he was talking about how there
was a report in the new york times that
donald trump has a corporation that paid
taxes in china
because apparently this corporation was
seeking to build a hotel in china at one
point and barack obama says
that that's a crazy story that right
there that's a bad story i mean if i had
a bank account in china
they'd call me beijing barry that's what
they call me by israeli barry okay first
of all
if anyone called him barry during his
entire presidency they were immediately
labeled racist because his name is
barack not barry even though he called
himself barry back in high school
number two the media would never call
him anything
anything they wouldn't call him late to
dinner
i mean like come on here's barack obama
proclaiming that he was a victim
of media excesses which is just oh my
god
we know that he continues to do business
with china
because he's got a secret chinese bank
account
how is that possible how is that
possible
a secret chinese bank account listen can
you imagine if i had a secret chinese
bank account
when i was running for reelection you
think fox news might have been a little
concerned about that
they would have called me beijing berry
okay so um
i'm glad that barack obama is having a
fun time on the stump uh barack obama
did receive campaign contributions in
2008 from foreign sources
he later had to return them barack obama
when it comes to foreign influence
he did promise the russians flexibility
on an open mic
in his 2012 reelection campaign and we
were we were told by the media that it
was a complete
nothing burger barack obama
in 2008 there was a tape of rashid
khalidi who's a spokesperson for the
palestine liberation organization like
natural terrorist organization
speaking warmly about barack obama that
tape was obtained by the la times they
never released it
yeah but he was a victim of the media
surely yeah you're right donald trump is
getting
a uh he's getting easy treatment by the
media here and then barack obama just
lies
to top all of it off he says that trump
messed up the economy now this is just a
lie i mean there's just an overt
falsehood
donald trump likes to claim he built
this economy
but america created 1.5 million more
jobs
in the last three years of the obama
biden administration
than in the first three years of the
trump pence administration
how you figure that and that was before
he could blame the pandemic
he did inherit the longest streak of job
growth in american history
but just like everything else he
inherited he messed it up okay
covet messed it up i mean it's just a
lie the the assumption that the american
people are too stupid to remember six
months ago or ten months ago is insane
but maybe maybe he's right maybe he's
right okay meanwhile
the senate democrats continue to push
forward with doing nothing
so their campaign is the same as the as
the biden campaign at this point and
that is
do nothing until donald trump is out of
the white house so
amy coney barrett is moving forward
toward a vote senate judiciary democrats
say they're going to
boycott today's vote on amy coney
barrett they put out a statement they
say this has been a sham process from
the beginning
weird since you all participated in the
judicial confirmation hearing
they say amidst a global pandemic an
ongoing election republicans are rushing
to confirm a supreme court
justice to take away health care from
millions and execute the extreme and
deeply unpopular agenda they've been
unable to get through congress
republicans broke the promises they made
and the rules they created when they
blocked merrick garland's nomination for
eight months under
under president obama then senate
majority leader
mitch mcconnell said the american people
should have a voice in the selection of
their next supreme court justice now
republicans have moved at breakneck
speed to jam through this nominee
ignoring her troubling record and
unprecedented evasions and breaking
long-standing committee rules to set
tomorrow's vote
okay that no no no no no no
when the party of the president and the
party of the senate are not the same
senators rarely vote for the nominees of
the president of the united states in an
election year
that just does not happen all that often
by the way
i love that they are saying that amy
coney barrett has a troubling record
they literally caught her on nothing
they caught her out on nothing and they
say unprecedented innovations oh you
mean her use of the ginsburg rule
established by one joe biden
on behalf of one ruth bader ginsburg
sure sure
so democrats say that they are not going
to grant this process any further
legitimacy by participating in a
committee markup of this nomination
just 12 days before the culmination of
an election that is already underway
okay fine tough catch you later
so they are they are not participating
in the judicial vote
tough tough again their whole philosophy
of the judiciary is completely perverse
erwin tremorinsky who is a first
amendment
law professor at university of
california berkeley has an entire piece
explaining why the left hates amy coney
barrett so much he says her philosophy
makes her incredibly dangerous why do we
really want our rights to be determined
by the understandings of centuries ago
well you can determine your right to the
ballot box
the the fact that the supreme court of
the united states is tasked with
interpreting a document
to mean what it meant that is not a
violation of rights it is a violation of
rights to have a bunch of people like
erwin tremorinsky sitting above you
and deciding for you what your rights
are trevorinski says originalists
believe the meaning of a constitutional
provision is fixed when it was adopted
it can be changed only by constitutional
amendment yep
under the under this view the first
amendment means the same thing as it was
as it
did when it was adopted in 1791 and the
14th amendment means the same thing as
when it was ratified in 1868.
yes because that's how law works
typically law doesn't magically change
and morph
based on circumstance the law means what
it meant if i heard a letter to my wife
today it speaks of my feelings for my
wife today
right it does not change it does not
morph it is not poetry
okay when you write that that is the
purpose of written language literally
the purpose of written language is to
codify what people are thinking
right then you wouldn't read a book by
dostoyevsky
and then try to interpret it as a racial
parable about america in 2020.
okay because dostoevsky wasn't writing
about that that's silly
okay but this is the silly
constitutional perspective of the left
tremorinsky says rights in the 21st
century should not be determined by the
understandings and views of centuries
ago that would lead to terrible results
the same congress that voted to ratify
the 14th amendment which assures equal
protection of the laws
also voted to segregate the district of
columbia public schools following
originalism would mean that brown vs
board of education was wrongly decided
in declaring laws requiring segregation
of schools
unconstitutional okay well let's play
that out
let's say for a second that the court
had not ruled the way that it did in
brown versus board of education
you know what would have happened the
civil rights act of 1964.
in fact it might have happened earlier
okay because as gerald rosenberg writes
in the hollow hope it is very rare that
the supreme court is a leader in any
capacity usually they simply follow the
legislature
or state legislatures and they simply
forecast a little bit ahead
the attempt to override the rule of law
in favor of results that you want is
incredibly incredibly dangerous but that
is of course what democrats want
from the court the good news is they
won't get it so they are boycotting the
amy coney barrett vote well tough
noogies who cares that doesn't that
doesn't matter
this thing is going through meanwhile
senate democrats have decided to block
another attempt to provide relief to the
american people thanks to covet
lockdowns
according to cnbc senate democrats
blocked republicans attempts to pass a
500 billion
coronavirus stimulus bill on wednesday
as house speaker nancy pelosi and
treasury secretary steve mnuchin make a
last-ditch
push to strike a relief deal before the
2020 election
now mitch mcconnell has been telling
trump not to go along with those
negotiations why
because mcconnell knows how this works
usually what happens is the mnuchin gets
in a room with pelosi
he immediately gives away the entire
store trump signs off on it and then it
turns out to be difficult to wrangle the
votes in the senate for a bad deal
so instead what you're saying is how
about this how about we pass what we
want to pass since we are the party of
the majority in the senate and uh and
then you just stand by that and then
nancy pelosi is the obstructionist
that is mitch mcconnell's position it
happens to be the correct position
senate democrats did obstruct yesterday
they once again filibustered a vote that
had majority approval
and the the measure failed in a 51-44
party-line vote
it required 60 votes to shut down the
filibuster
the stalemate in the senate extends
months of gridlock on capitol hill
as millions of americans trying to
afford food and housing and keep their
businesses open
await more federal aid during an
economic crisis election year politics
have jarred the legislative process
as new covenant 19 infections reached
levels unseen in weeks republicans in
congress
argue that democrats have reached for an
expensive wish list filled with many
provisions
unrelated to the crisis mcconnell has
said that
democrats are engaging in all or nothing
obstruction as they hold out for a
comprehensive deal worth about
two trillion dollars it's the federal
government between the federal reserve
and the money that has already been
allocated by congress we've spent
something like six to seven
trillion dollars so far democrats want
another two trillion dollars
not a narrow relief package tailored to
helping people in the now they want to
bail out states for all of their bad
union contracts
going back years they want a bunch of
unrelated provisions stacked into a
giant pork bill
democrats meanwhile say that the bill is
quote unquote partisan and emaciated
the legislation before the senate on
wednesday included funds for a second
paycheck protection program loan
for struggling small businesses a 300
per week supplemental unemployment
insurance benefit and liability
protections for businesses
among other provisions it didn't include
another round of direct payments to
people instead it was
designed to get businesses up and
running again
both pelosi and mark meadows said they
aim to have a deal in place before the
end of the week
but of course every time the white house
takes a step toward the democrats
position
they risk losing republican support and
it is unlikely that mcconnell is going
to bring
forth a bill that does not have at least
a majority of republicans
in support of the bill so democrats
continue to obstruct
covet relief that is no shock they have
very little interest in the needs of the
american people
this is all about electioneering at this
point
okay we'll be back here later today with
two additional hours of content plus go
subscribe over to daily wire because
tonight
is the final presidential debate we will
be covering that live
also tune in tomorrow for my debate
recap i'm sure it'll be a doozy this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick shien
the show is edited by adam syavette
audio mix by mike caromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
democrats can drive a new non-traversing
about president trump rudy giuliani gets
caught adjusting his microphone that's a
big scandal
and leftists argue that social media are
biased
in favor of conservatives how about that
check it out on the michael knowles show
you